اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
الخاصه التي حصلت عليها العربيه لعمليات
الاجلاء الفرنسيه من السودان نحو جيبوتي
كان الرئيس ماكرون قد اعلن بان فرنسا اجلت
538 شخصا من السودان بينهم
فرنسيين اعلن ايضا كذلك عن اصابه احد
الجنود الفرنسيين خلال عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان ايضا قبل قليل كانت قد اعلنت
اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه بان عمليه الاجلاء
من السودان نحو جيبوتي قد انتهت اذن هذه
صور كما ذكرنا قبل قليل صور خاصه
للعربيه اثناء نقل بعض طبعا المعدات
والمركبات ايضا كذلك
اخلاء السفاره ربما الفرنسيه تماما في
الخرطوم ونقل كل العاملين والموظفين
والبعث الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
واجلائهم تماما من السودان نحو جيبوتي عبر
احدى الطائرات
النقل او الشحن الكبيره كما نشاهد الان
على الشاشه امامنا اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه
كانت قد ذكرت ايضا بان هناك
فرقاطه فرنسيه ستظل قرب بورت سودان لتساعد
في عمليات الاجلاء الامميه اذا اركان
الجيش الفرنسيه كانت قد اعلنت انتهاء
العمليه وقالت بان عمليه الاجراء الفرنسيه
من السودان شملت احدى واربعين جنسيه
بالاضافه ايضا لتصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون والذي قال بان فرنسا نجحت
باجلاء 538
شخصا من الخرطوم اعلن عن اصابه احد الجنود
الفرنسيين ايضا
خلال هذه العمليات لم
تابعه تقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات